a look inside kourtney kardashian and
travis barker's
sexy 10 days in quarantine keep it
fresh keep people interested courtney
made the best of quarantine with her man
sharing a series of new shots to
instagram of all the festivities the
pair enjoyed
captioning her post quote 10 days of
quarantine
i'm just like living life in this pic
court goes topless for a mirror selfie
she's got only a black robe on travis is
in the background
and here she shows off a pic of what
appears to be her chopped off locks
courtney's friend sarah howard credited
travis for cutting his lady's hair in
the comment section
and courtney confirmed it by writing
quote good with his hands
we also got a glimpse of the shows the
couple seems to be into
mayor of easttown and manifest i love it
court never explained why the pair was
in lockdown but we also see
this pick of her kiddos peering through
their glass door and here it seems they
had time to enjoy
some s'mores whatever happens happens
a source recently told et that the
couple is just living in the moment
and enjoying each day and added quote
courtney and travis really recognize now
more than ever
how special their relationship is and
how fortunate they are to spend their
time together
whether it's just the two of them with
friends or with their families
a source also said we should expect to
see travis appear on the kardashians new
hulu reality show
if you'll remember during the keeping up
with the kardashians series finale
reunion
chloe called out courtney for not
sharing as much of her personal life
as she did at the beginning of the
series i think court learned from
how much the public was in her
relationship with scott it made her not
want to share
future dating relationships and we
weren't even allowed to talk about it
we're not saying to put him on but
courtney wouldn't even let us
mention even though there's paparazzi
photos so we were
frustrated that we couldn't even talk
about what courtney was doing
here's hoping we'll see more of kravis
on social media
and tv i love you
[Music]
you